A second method to adapt cases is to
use case based reasoning recursively.
So last time we considered problem
which I had to go from my office
to a restaurant, and
I found a way of doing that.
Now suppose that I have to go from
my home to the same restaurant.
So I don't yet know how to go from
my home to the restaurant, but
I know how to go from
my home to my office.
And this last time, I figured out a way
of going from office to the restaurant.
So there we have it.
Now I have a case retrieved for
going from home to office, another case
retrieved for going from office to
the restaurant, and I have a solution.
We're going from home all
the way to the restaurant.
This is an example of
case based reasoning.
Your first time you retrieve a case for
solving a problem,
the case provides a partial solution.
So I take the remaining part which was
not solved, make it a new problem,
and send it back into the case memory.
Now the case memory finds me a new case.
And I take this new case and
I compose it with the previous
case to get a full solution.
>> So to return again to our programming
example, when I'm designing a program,
my file input is usually
part of a broader problem of
persisting data between
instances of the program.
And thus, the real problem I'm solving
is solving this problem of how to save
data when the program isn't running.
I can then solve that problem
recursively by breaking it down
into the first problem of file input and
the second problem of file output.
I might draw a case for solving file
input from one program I've done in
the past and a case for solving file
output from another program in the past.
So I've solved it recursively by
breaking it down into sub problems.
>> David,
to build on what you just said,
the same kind of thing
occurs in design in general.
Often when we do design, we get
partial solutions for multiple cases.
For example, consider the problem
of designing a microbot
that can swim underwater
in a very stealthy manner.
This might remind me
of a case of a copepod
which has large number of appendages and
swims in the water at very slow velocity
making minimum wake in the water.
That's good,
I've now solved part of the problem,
the part which had to do with moving
stealthily underwater under slow speeds.
But that now sets up a new goal,
how do I achieve stealthy motion
underwater at high speeds?
And I may come up with a solution
from a different case.
So a squid, for example, also swims
stealthily underwater, but it does so
by creating a wake that matches
the natural wake of water around it.
So here I first used the goal
of designing a microbot that can
swim underwater stealthily to
retrieve a case of the copepod.
That provide me with a partial solution.
So I set up a new sub-goal
to complete the solution.
The new sub-goal found a new case,
that of the squid,
which gave me the rest of the solution.
And if I compose the two partial
solutions, I get the complete solution.
>> So what Ashok just described is
something that we call compound analogy,
which is a specific type of
adaptation by recursive reasoning.
If you're interested in that example,
we've provided a paper on it in
the course materials for this lesson.
So you can read more about the process
of adapting those cases to solve that
very unique and complex design problem.